so every made her debut in Episode three
of the new season of my ear academia
specifically in the end credits scene so
it wasn't very long but seeing as she's
been introduced as a character I thought
it might be worth doing a video showing
exactly what her quirk is but I want to
do this without revealing any plot
spoilers so I'm gonna kind of examine
the quirk in isolation what I mean by
that is I'll describe how it can
hypothetically be used without
describing how Airy herself has actually
used it every squawk is known as rewind
and it's definitely not too far from
being classed as an instant kill quirk
it's unique in the sense that it bears
no resemblance to any other power we've
seen in the show and it granted the
ability to turn a person's body back
into a previous state but this has two
different meanings
okay so firstly we know for a fact that
the quirk can rewind people's genetics
meaning that if she touched a human she
could essentially rewind that DNA and
de-evolve them so as an example
considering how in the world of my hero
academia human beings have evolved into
a state of having quirks this power
could essentially be used to rewind them
back to a time when humans had no powers
whatsoever alternatively you could use
it in a different way and you could
touch a person and rewind them back into
a monkey
if you subscribe to the theory of
evolution that is now the other way in
which this quirk works is completely
different from this
so rather than be evolving someone it
can also be used to rewind a person's
actual growth so she could rewind
someone back into a baby or even rewind
someone just a little bit to get rid of
their injuries or their illnesses but
the most interesting thing about this
power and this is a thing that no one
really talks about is confirmed that
this quirk is an accumulation type quirk
that means in order for it to be
activated the user has to accumulate a
currently unknown element so if you're
confused an accumulation type quirk is
something where you have to build up a
certain element over time to use it an
example would be Dec who's one for
awkward so that's a stockpiling ability
so that means that the strength has been
built up over a long period of time
which is why deku himself is so strong
because there's been eight previous
people who've been building up this
power there are many other quirks like
this characters like fat gum and other
characters like reader stroke
they have accumulation type quirks and I
didn't actually say what their quirks
were so nobody accuse me of spoilers
okay arias quirk works in the same way
she has to accumulate something over
time for her rewind ability to activate
but like I said we don't know what it is
though I feel personally is something to
do with emotion like happiness for
example or fear or I don't exactly know
okay but I feel like it's something to
do with emotion
now the quirk itself only affects living
things and so it's hard for the user to
practice it without hurting people like
imagine if someone wanted to practice
that quirk on you knowing that you could
be potentially rewound back to a point
where you never even existed I'm not
sure I'd want to take that chance no
matter how much I trusted you and that's
the reason I refer to it as an instant
kill quo because you can literally just
just do that to someone by accident and
one last thing on this power when it's
activated the horn in her head actually
grows bigger and it glows quite brightly
and that my friends was every squawk
explained really appreciate it if you
would subscribe especially if you liked
that video
I've more coming out in the very near
future I do at least one video a week
and be sure to check out some of the
other videos on my channel including
myrio explained and one of my videos
which has become a lot more popular
recently
Hawks explained thanks for watching and
I'll catch you next week peace